ok so the question is
the totalitarian forms of expression we have seen so far have been masculine
But maybe we see something else now
I don't think it's anything else
It is something similar
who has spread its influence
Imagine that there is an essential feminine pathology
just as there is an essential masculine pathology. Freud clearly laid the essential feminine pathology
"Oedipus mother"
That's the mother there
coming too close to her children
that interferes too much with them
There, in trying to protect them, will undermine them
in a fatal way
There is a classic representation of the feminine in the West
The Mother of Jesus
One of those representations
that is beautiful
Maria has her foot on a snake
And she keeps Christ up like that
That is exactly how mothers have always done
It is a biological portrait of the human woman
who keeps his infant away
the horrible snake-like predator
it is obvious
But adult people are not infants
And neither are children
and if you treat them as such, you undermine them
You make them sick and make them old babies
It's ugly
the freudian nightmare
It happens quite often in therapy
one can have a terrible relationship with his father
often because he was
absent, abusive or tyrantical
But the common morality around mother is that she did everything for you
What is left as you can do?
Nothing!
Including never leaving home
That is the motivation
for the woman who is the overprotective mother there is nothing besides
To take care of
infants
You just care to keep them as babies
so they never leave one
.... maybe they'll kill one when you sleep
but they never leave home
It is comical to see the postmodern feminists
waffle that gender does not exist
while in their actions
plays the archetypal devouring mother at the same time
They believe that the world can be divided into predators
and infants
The predators are evil and must be stopped
and the infants you have to take care of
That's how Mother does
But adults are not children
and you destroy them that way
especially teenagers who just started their development
There is a rule I tried to follow
when I had young children
Do nothing for them as they can
That rule is piss annoying
It takes 15 seconds to wear a 2 year old clothes
When he himself has to do it, it is 15 min
or 20 or 30
But if you teach them, you no longer have to
And they can do well
And you do that with everything
"no you can now"
"I love you so much that I will do it for you"
I do not like you at all if I say so
I will not do anything for you as soon as I can
How to work in a nursing home
Don't do anything for the old ones
as they can do for themselves, then they steal the last independence from them
This is how you act as a manager
You make yourself superfluous
by spreading autonomy
so the people on the floor can handle it all by themselves
You don't do that by doing everything for people
and not at all by dividing the world
completely uncritical
up in predators
and victims, infants
then pretend to protect them
You can't protect people
only make them strong
that's all
then they can protect themselves
And then they don't need you
and from there the pathology emerges
"never leave me"
"I will do everything for you, but never forsake me"
The Freudian nightmare
You separate the child from himself
You separate them from your husband
and you fertilize the soil for their independence
It is one of the reasons why it is useful for a mother and a father
The mother will have to fall in love with the infant
otherwise she will throw it out of the window
They are insanely demanding and always right
The right month to treat a small infant
"I do everything for you and you are always right
Your needs are more important than everyone else's
and anyone who threatens you is terrible "
But when the child starts to crawl
is the right attitude -
"see getting started"
Men who are less prone to negative emotions
and have less compassion
is better at fostering this type of independence
so it is usually the men
who play wild games
push them forward and say "get started. You can do it"
It is difficult for a mother to be in both roles
because she must fall in love with the infant
that it is difficult to be universal nursing mother
and disciplining at the same time
for the roles are contradictory
Now there are lots of women in politics
and they have taken their essential characteristics
while saying "essential traits do not exist"
Well they do!